In this video, I'm going to explain a
concept that I believe is probably one
of the most important things you can
have as a copywriter, marketer, or
creative strategist. It is truly what
separates beginners and good copywriters
from great copywriters. And I promise
you, it is absolutely nothing that
you've ever heard before or had anyone
teach before. I know that is a big
claim, but I'm going to back it up. If
you've been on this channel and you've
gone through Copy Blocks, which is the
first video I ever did on this page and
the one with the most views, and you
found that useful, which many of you
have, or even bought the product below
where we go like a super deep dive into
it, and you're like, "Damn, Copy Blocks
changed the way that I do marketing and
advertising," which I've heard many
times before. This is going to be like
the advanced course. It's going to take
you to the next level. And I promise it
will probably open your eyes to stuff
that you never even considered in the
past. and maybe for some stuff that you
have considered, it's going to give you
a language and a vocabulary for stuff
that you're already doing, which is
going to help you be even more advanced
and a lot sharper. Those are really big
claims, but I feel absolutely confident
in making them. Before we get into it,
uh, if it's your first time on this
channel, my name is Luke Eh, and my
business partner, Mario Castelli, and I
are copywriters who have generated over
$und00 million each with our copy. Those
are real numbers, and they're probably
much, much higher. I know one VSSL I did
did $100 million, so I know that that's
the limit, okay? But it's definitely
more than that. Now we have a community
of over 412 creative strategists. I got
to update this number. It keeps going
up. Uh that's called Genesis. We help
people make winning ads, funnels, and a
[__] ton of money. Especially creative
strategists and people in the DDC ecom
space. We also run the creative cartel,
which is a private invite only
membership with creative strategists for
eight and nine figure brands like these
ones on here, which average about a
billion dollars in spend. And then
here's a wall of some of our recent
wins. 7K plus 1.3% performance bonus.
This is someone inside of my active me
mentorship that I'm running right now.
Uh here's another Genesis member. Uh
here's another business owner inside of
Genesis. Uh here's another business
owner inside of Genesis. Here's another
active member. He's also uh inside of
our mentorship. 5K plus 3% spend deal.
Uh just reached 40K per month. Got my
first client in the second week. And you
can just go on, right? We do a horrible
job at collecting our testimonials. So,
this is the best that I can do. And you
can check those out. I'll have a link
down below if you want to check our
pedigree a little bit more. Now, let's
get into the fun part. So, first is what
is copy instincts? Okay, we even did a
workshop on this not too long ago, and
this is going to take some of this
material, but it's also an updated
version. Even if you watched the the
workshop, come back in here to refresh
yourself. So, Copy Instincts was born
after analyzing nearly 412 hours of copy
feedback inside of our Genesis program.
It's conveniently the same number as my
Genesis members. Maybe I fudged that.
The reason I say 412 hours, I just did
the math a little bit ago, is inside of
Genesis, we do a three-hour long
A-listister or feedback call every
single Thursday. Um, this basically
means that any Genesis member can come
on and my business partner and I will go
through as many people as we can,
usually 15, 20 plus people, and we'll
just give them feedback on their copy.
And the results that we get from this
are are [__] phenomenal. People
increase their conversion percentages,
their webinars start working, their ads
start working, their landing clients. I
mean, the results that people get from
these calls are extraordinary, and
they're really hard to do. We've been
doing them for a long time. So, three
hours every single week, multiply that
times about two to threeish years, plus
all the other feedback that Mario and I
have uh given in the past. And I promise
that there's probably nobody else on
earth who has uh reviewed and analyzed
more copy than him and I. Okay? There's
maybe some people who are close, but I I
think we're probably the most. And the
reason why this is important to you is
because what I did is I took all of
those transcripts and calls and I was
like, I need to extract all of the
lessons. So, of course, I threw it into
our friend AI and I started to extract
like what is going on here? And I
started to notice a pattern that I had
never noticed before, which is that
Mario and I had an instinct that allowed
us to solve uh marketing problems. This
is extremely important because people
have been in our Genesis program uh for
a while. They know all the concepts that
we've taught them, right? And we have a
bunch of [__] concepts. Copy blocks,
beat map, unique mechanism,
intensification. Like we're [__] out
concepts. Cache method, cast method,
storming, like tons of stuff that people
found in insanely valuable and use all
the time. People in our community
understood what these concepts were, but
there was something missing, something
that stopped them from being able to go
from um like what was on the page to be
able to edit things for themselves,
right? I was basically asking the
question like, what are we even good
for? like what are we doing that's
working that's different than what other
people were doing. And I realized that
it was because they were not asking
themselves the right questions, which
seems kind of cute, but it's a really
important point because asking yourself
the right questions is the same thing as
having the right instincts. Okay? And
again, I knew this was valuable because
people have generated millions of
dollars from these calls. So, we wanted
to see if we could codify what an
instinct was and then teach it to people
because again, if you can ask yourself
or AI the right questions, you will
consistently generate the right answers.
I've proven this with people. when I
start asking them the right questions,
they usually always generate the right
answers. And of course, if you ask the
right questions to AI, AI will generate
you really powerful, profound um
answers. So, the difference was not
about teaching a new concept. That's
what's interesting about copy instincts.
I'm not going to be here just teaching
you new concepts. I'll be using concepts
we taught in the past, but I'm going to
be more training and priming your
instinct so you always know what to look
at, uh, where to go, like where you're
trying to take the copy in the
messaging, and then how to generate it,
right? And it's something that's like
way deeper and way more internal and way
more profound. Okay, so hopefully this
works. So, what are copy instincts? I
went through and tried to come up with a
solid definition. This is the best that
I have so far. A copy instinct is a
question that you've asked so many
times, it turns into a feeling. That's
why it's an instinct, okay? It's a
question and an impulse that you
literally feel in your body. The feeling
that something on the page is off. The
feeling of where the best version lives
and the feel for the move that gets you
there. That's some basic AI speak, but
it's three important things. One, it's
your perception. So, what you're able to
see when you look at a piece of copy.
The next one is um what I call the
attraction instinct. So, it's like I can
look at my copy and I can see what's
going on. My perception is clear. My
next instinct is how do I take where I'm
at and like where am I trying to go?
Like where am I trying to take this copy
to? And the last one is how do I
actually get there? Okay,
so like I said, you can use the acronym
SAM. I may move this around, but for now
it's see, attract, and make. And this is
really profound. Um, and you'll see in a
second. The other thing that's important
to understand is that copy instincts
operate at all levels of copy. So big
idea mechanism, add copy, hooks, and
headline. Um, so we're going to look at
those different examples. And this will
be a part one. There will be a part two
because there's so much to cover in
here. Now, some big rules before we get
into copy instincts. One is that you're
going to see this happen all the time is
what I call psychology verse facts. And
really what this should be is psychology
over facts. So, when you're doing
marketing, I'm not saying to lie. I'm
not even saying you need to bend the
truth. I'm just saying the most
effective marketing is when you are
primarily focused on the psychology and
then you're looking for facts that will
support it. It's kind of a form of
cherrypicking, right? And to some degree
it can be a seem a little bit dishonest
and people use it dishonestly all the
time. How you use this is up to you, but
I'm saying the way to come up with the
best possible marketing ideas is to
always start by thinking about the
psychology, which is what we're going to
be doing versus the facts. The way the
reason that a lot of people get stuck
with their ideation and their hooks is
that they're trying to look in their
facts and come up with an idea within
the facts. That's not how it works.
Typically, you need to understand the
psychology of what it is you're trying
to create and then figure out how you
can make that be true. The next one is
to commit to one idea. Okay? So, we're
monogamous with to our ideas. And
everything I'm talking about is a
probability and not a truth. I am the
first person who will be delighted and
happy to be wrong. I love being [__]
wrong, especially when it comes to
advertising because it keeps me humble
and keeps me close to the [__] truth.
Anyone who thinks they know all the
secrets of the universe, especially when
it comes to something as crazy as the
psychology of tons of different people,
they're lying to you. Okay? At the end
of the day, the ad account and the
customer and those people, they are the
final arbiters of truth. If it works for
them, awesome. So, everything I'm
talking about is a rule of thumb. Don't
take it for gospel. So, the first thing
we talked about is the C, the perceptual
instincts. You have to be able to see
issues before you can fix them. And most
copywriters are blind. This is why these
are the three types of instincts or
things that you need, I believe, as a
copywriter in order to have the proper
perception to look at a piece of copy
and understand what's wrong with it and
how you want to move it. So, the first
one is copy blocks, which there's a
video on this channel you can watch.
There's also a product you can purchase
down below for $27. People, we keep it
alive even though the the page looks
like we're selling dick pills. That's
the feedback that I get. It's an old ass
page. It doesn't matter. The product is
amazing. The concepts are amazing and
people have consistently give us amazing
feedback on it. Okay, I don't care if
you buy or not. I'm just letting you
know what they tell me all the time. The
next one is something called
interception, metacognition and uh
sematic awareness and then gray verse
color. All right, so copy blocks I'll
explain in a second. Uh I actually
explained all of these. So copy blocks
is really easy. It's just understanding
that most copy is made up of three
different psychological elements. Pain,
promise, proof, curiosity, constraints,
and conditions. Most of these are pretty
clear. The these three down here um are
a little need a little more work. So
curiosity is anything that's interesting
and curiosity invoking. Okay, it's just
interesting. It's fun. Um it's also your
mechanism. So it's the bridge between
your pain and your promise oftentimes
because we like to make that something
new and novel and curious. The other one
is constraints. So constraints are
things that hold you back. Okay, these
can be things like um types of beliefs.
The big ones are always time, money,
effort. Conditions are things like
urgency, scarcity, discounts, uh all
that kind of mechanical stuff that you
typically say around the offer section
or the close section of your copy or
your ad. All right? And here's just an
example. Here's a headline. The
three-pillar system that's helped a
thousand freelancers go from struggling
to building predictable revenue in six
weeks, not years. Only 15 slots left. I
don't think this is the greatest
headline ever. I actually don't think
it's a good headline. I don't think it's
a bad headline. I just think it's
somewhere between bad and good. And
we'll talk about that in the next video.
But it's a good illustration of the
three-pillar system. That's our
curiosity mechanism. uh helped build uh
predictable revenue. So this is the
promise. A thousand freelancers is a
form of proof. Go from struggling to
whatever is a form of pain. In six weeks
are your uh constraints, right? So it
doesn't take time. And only 15 slots
left is a uh conditions uh for scarcity.
Okay? Now you don't be a nerd. Okay? I'm
going to say that many times. Like that
actually should be its own. Don't be a
[__] nerd because everything I'm
talking about is just to help you see
things a little bit more clearly. Not
everything. Some copy blocks are like
the same thing, right? Two, one piece of
copy could be two copy blocks, right? Or
where's the line between it? It doesn't
really matter. As long as you have a
rough understanding of what these
elements are, you're okay. The next one
is really important, which is what I
call interception. This is how your
ability to feel within your body. Most
people think I'm getting woo woo because
I do love to get woo woo with things,
but people think I'm getting woo woo
when I talk about this, but it's it's
the most practical thing in the world.
Every great copywriter and marketer I
know loves looking at ads. like when an
ad comes, they don't like having ad
blockers on in general, okay? They don't
they like to look at ads and one of the
things that they'll always pay attention
to when they're in a sales process, when
they're buying something, when they're
I've seen this consistently, and I've
only heard a few people talk about it.
They will pay so close attention to what
they're experiencing in their body as
they're getting sold to. They're so
aware of it. They're paying attention to
like what things were said that made me
shift. What beliefs were I having? What
things? And they're so hyper aware of
how they get sold to and how they're
marketed to because we're all humans.
Like I get marketed to. There's ideas in
my head that were not my original ones.
I get sold to all the time. U it comes a
little bit harder I think as you do this
work. But um regardless the ability to
feel your thoughts, your feelings, and
your sensations, and your emotions,
that's what an experience is composed
of. What am I thinking? What am I
feeling like sematically in my body?
like a tingling, a buzzing, whatever.
What emotions am I having? Right? Mad,
sad, happy, afraid, stimulated, like
what emotions am I having? Um,
and uh, thoughts, feelings, emotions. I
think that's basically it. Yeah,
thoughts, feelings, and emotions. Maybe
there's another one I missed. I thought
I said four. But thoughts, feelings, and
emotions basically make up uh your
your uh experience. So interception is
like literally right now, can you feel
your butt in your hair and on and your
chair, not on your hair? Can you uh
notice your breathing? Can you notice
tightness in your neck? Right? Can you
notice a thought that you had? Can you
had this? It's a powerful experience.
And when you look at copy, can you do
this? Because that's going to increase
your perception. And you probably
already have it. You just could probably
enhance your attention to it. The last
one is what I call gray verse color.
It's a little confusing because this is
all color and stuff like this, but gray
verse color is something different.
Ultimately, what this comes down to is
boring verse interesting. Okay. Another
way to look at it is unique verse like
boilerplate. So, when I look at a piece
of copy and when I look at great
copywriters look at pieces of copy, one
thing they're always paying attention to
is what is the most interesting thing
that's being said in this copy? Because
if you're selling a testosterone
supplement, for instance, most of your
pain points and your promises are going
to be the same. like how you can only
compete on making stronger pain points
and promises for so long before some
Brazilian guy is going to come out and
say the most absurd outrageous thing
possible and make you know Morgan
Freeman and and Chuck Norris come back
to life, not Morgan Freeman, but Chuck
Norris come back to life and and sell a
bunch of stuff. Okay, if you know how
Brazilians run their VSSLs, you know
what I'm talking about. My point is you
can only go so far by making claims like
promises, promise proof, those kind of
things. So, what you need to do is you
need to start looking at um like what is
the stuff that stands out. Okay, usually
this is your curiosity block is what
you're looking for. Okay, but you're
looking for like the most interesting
ideas. And again, it's usually a mixture
of copy blocks and interception. So, my
advice would be literally if you really
want to do this exercise, well, pause
this video.
So, pause
and then come down here. Pause. Awesome.
The purpose of what you want to do is
you want to go through this uh piece of
copy, this ad, and you want to pay
attention to what are the parts that
seem interesting to me. So, let's just
go through it together. And we'll use
we'll use this for instance.
Okay. If you oil your beard daily and
it's still dry, you're not doing it
wrong. You're using the wrong product
entirely. Okay. That's a
semi-interesting idea. Here's why it's
not your fault. The oil you're using,
whether it's from the drugstore, was
formulated for straight hair. Okay?
Okay. And this is a a product that's for
uh I believe black men uh for their
beards on your hair. It just sits on top
and does nothing.
Okay. So, this right here is
boilerplate. This is kind of like, oh,
you tried this stuff. It didn't work
before.
Look, here's something that's
interesting.
Okay. Everything else is just like kind
of the basic stuff that you're going to
talk about in an ad. Okay. So, if I'm uh
looking at this, I have this idea that's
basically uh using the wrong product,
which actually, to be honest, I don't
love that idea. So, we'll move it. um
oil was formulated for straight hair.
And then we could do this uh sits on top
and does nothing. It's a cool um visual.
Never designed to work for your hair.
Your hair 4B curls so tight that skin uh
whatever. So we could say um
and then two brothers from Atlanta. The
rest falls under the same category.
Now looking at this again, I would
actually kind of move that using the
wrong product. That's kind of
boilerplate. So we have these ideas. Oil
was formulated for straight hair. Never
designed to work for your hair. It sits
on top and does nothing. 4 B 4C hairs
curled so tight oil can't move two
brothers from Atlanta. These are the
most interesting elements to me that I
think are in this ad. This is really
really really important to pay attention
to these because if I want to improve
this ad or I want to come up with new
new ad ideas or if I'm looking at a
swipe or uh organic and I'm trying to
come up with ideas, I need to pay
attention to what are the most
interesting things to me, right? What
kind of gets my like literally it's
almost like a little tingle in your body
when you look at you're like oh your
heart beats a little bit. you're like,
"Oh, that's a cool idea." Because if I
take those ideas now, I know that I can
come up with new ad ideas. I know I can
make these ideas as strong as possible,
which I'll show you how to do a little
bit later. So, it's a really powerful
tool. Okay, so hopefully that makes
sense. The first thing that we've done
is just help you with the perceptual
instincts by using copy blocks,
interception, and understanding the
difference between something that's
interesting and boring. So, now let's
move on to what I call the attractor
instincts. This is actually the center
and potentially the most important part
of copy instincts. It's most important
when designing big ideas and mechanisms
and it's probably the trickiest to do
because it incorporates the following
elements. Okay, this is really the heart
of what copy instincts are about. Okay,
probably the most important thing that
people do is they'll come and they'll
bring us a product and we'll help um
position it, come up with the mechanism
and figure things out. And people
struggle with this. So if you understand
this this process, which you know it
takes time and experience, but hopefully
this video will shortcut that immensely
for you. So in order to do it, what you
do is you take these following elements.
So uniqueness, novelty, preeminence,
associations, magical thinking, culture,
zeitgeist, coherence, and more. And what
you do is you play around with these
different elements in your product until
you come up with an idea that is really,
really powerful. Okay, so uniqueness and
novelty is again, it's pretty
self-explanatory. Preeminence is
anything that you can say you're a
category of one in or you're the best
at, the most, the fastest, the biggest,
whatever that is. Associations and
magical thinking are just understanding
that humans um we don't always think
logically. We think in terms of
associations and so um and AI does to a
degree as well but let's not get into
that. So associations and magical
thinking is a powerful tool that you can
use. I'll use one example. So um if you
look at like organ supplements so the
idea is um if you eat reindeer testicles
you will get more testosterone. Okay.
Now logically you can make that argument
and there is a logical argument to be
made there. I don't know what the
science is. But the most important part
is probably 99% of the buyers don't
actually know what the science is. They
trust it. But more importantly, they
trust the association and the magical
thinking. They trust the structure of
the idea. What do I mean by that? The
idea is very simple. The idea is saying
um testicles make testosterone. So if
you eat that animal, you will then get
more testosterone. Reindeers are really
big and strong and powerful. Therefore,
if you eat from them, you'll get big and
powerful. Or a bison or whatever those
things are. Okay? If you really dig
down, that's the majority of how people
are buying. And that kind of thinking is
not scientific and it's definitely not
logical. It's almost a form of
shamanism, right? So, when you see those
guys, those [__] Aztecs back in the
day wearing like a jaguar cloak and we
kind of look at that and they they wore
it because they believe that like the
magic and the energy was going to make
them powerful and we you can kind of
laugh at it, but it's literally exact.
The guy eating a [__] like bison
organs is doing the exact same thing as
the guy wearing a jaguar skin fighting.
Okay? Because it's a form of shamanism.
It's magical thinking. You think that
just because I use some crazy examples,
but it's like if you I'm gonna use a PG
example, but it's like if you take
Cristiano Ronaldo's toenails, right, and
rub them on your wear them in your socks
and rub them on your feet, is that going
to make you a better football player?
Like, not really, but why not, right?
It's almost the same exact idea. Again,
I'm not disputing the science or the
actual thinking behind it or saying that
people are dumb. I'm just saying that
this carries a lot more weight than
people give it credit for often. The
other one is culture and zeitgeist. So
so much of writing effective hooks and
making effective ad copy is by
understanding how to kind of surf the
zeitgeist. A zeitgeist just stands for
the the spirit of the time. So it's like
like what are people going at? What's a
controversial thing to say? Um what's
going to trigger people? Where are
people at? Right? Um where's mass
consciousness at? How can we start to
provoke that? It's really kind of
playing with those elements. And then
coherence is how do you fit all these
things together? It's a little tricky,
but I'll I'll try to explain it to you.
So, the trick is that you have to play
around with these and balance
possibilities for these elements to
click into one place. So, what I mean by
that is sometimes you'll look at a
product and there will be two or three
things that you can say are really
unique about it. And you could find a
couple things that it could be a
category of one in, right? So, you're
trying to figure out directions to
position it. So, you're kind of playing
around with it. Oh, what if I highlight
this element and this element? Okay.
Well, what if I highlight this element
and this element? And you're looking for
the greatest arrangement where things
sort of click into place. And hopefully
I'll show you an example of that. That's
when I call something a lock, coherence,
resonance. And this will make sense in a
moment. I know this is abstract, but I'm
going to make it really concrete. In
order to figure out the best solution,
you have to know the big primary outcome
that you're looking for. Okay? So, the
reason I call these attractor instincts
is this is an instinct in your body of
where you're trying to go for. So, once
you can see and look at a piece of copy
or a mechanism and see the components,
then you can check in with yourself and
say, um, could I take this idea and move
it in a specific direction, right? Could
I make this idea stronger? So, what does
stronger mean?
Here's here's the best way that I
understand it, and this is how the best
marketers in the world think, in my
opinion. What would have to be true
about the world for this to be the best
possible solution? So, think about this
for a moment. What would have to be true
about the world for this to be the best
possible solution? You're not thinking
about how how do I describe my product
as the best? Nope. You reverse engineer
it. You say, most people, here's some
hot sauce. Okay? Most people will say,
"All right, here's some hot sauce. I'm
going to describe all the things about
the hot sauce that make this the
absolute best hot sauce. The best
marketers in the world will step back
and say, "If I had infinite budget,
infinite time, and infinite genius, and
I were to design the best possible hot
sauce, what would have to be true about
the world and my process for me to come
to this solution?" Because most products
and most things are built out of
convenience. They're built out of
copying somebody else. They're built out
of um, you know, a trend. They're built
out of some random idea, right? They're
built out of some sort of scarcity,
whether it's time or resources, right?
Most people don't have the platonic best
possible product, right? But as a
marketer, our job is to tell the story
as if that is the case. So, we reverse
engineer. And I would say, okay, I
wanted to design the best possible hot
sauce. Well, um, if I were to do that,
like what would I what would I be
focused on? Okay, I'd be focused on the
ratio of the flavor to the heat. And I
would talk about the the way that the
heat is and the different types of heat.
and you would need the best kind of
peppers and you would need this and I
would come up with what is my worldview
for it and how would that lead me
perfectly to coming up with habanero as
the best solution with these best
perfect ingredients right and then I
would tell a story of the founder and
I'm putting all of those elements
together ultimately you're not selling a
product or an outcome you're selling a
worldview and if you sell the worldview
then the product falls out of that I
understand that this is uh a little
abstract especially if it's your first
time hearing it so stay with me there's
multiple videos and you can come back
and hopefully some things will Makes
sense. Here's an explanation. And if you
click down below and join the email
list, you'll get access to this doc. You
can play around with it. There's a
single orientation that generates all of
them. This is what AI was telling me
when they analyze our calls. Without it,
the individual reflexes are just tricks.
With it, they emerge naturally. You see,
so me and Mario, every product as a
universe of emotional and narrative
potential. Your reflex is to find the
most intense, most coherent, most
defensible version of that universe.
then construct it completely so the
reader can't find the exit. A student
sees a dog collar and thinks, "How do I
describe this dog collar?" You see a dog
collar and think, "What is the most
emotionally devastating, biologically
grounded, narratively coherent reality I
can build in which this dog collar is
the inevitable solution to a crisis the
reader didn't know they were causing?"
Those are not different skill levels.
They are different modes of perception.
The student looks at the product, you
look through the product into the world,
etc., etc. The core idea is that you
have an attractor that's drawing you to
making your product the platonic ideal
of a solution. When you know that that's
your north star, then you can use the
following moves to help you get there.
So you can ask yourself questions like,
what's most unique about this? This, by
the way, is once you know that that's
what you're trying to do, this is the
process to do it. What's most unique
about this product? How can we make
those elements preeminent? How can we
borrow associations and magical thinking
to make those elements even more
pristine? How can we make the specific
unique combination of the perfect
combination in our current time and
place? How can we make all of this
coherent? In other words, boom. Okay,
this is an example that I've done inside
of Genesis many, many times. So, I'm
going to show you right now because I
think it's just a clear example of this.
So, let's say that I'm marketing and
selling this. I know it looks like porn,
but it's PDRN. It's an anti-aging
solution. And I'm looking at, all right,
I want to make some ads for this thing.
You know, mechanisms like where the [__]
do I begin? First thing I would say is
what is most unique about this product
that can't be said about anyone else.
That's really what I'm looking for. Now,
for some products, this won't be the
case. So, you're going to have to do
your best. If you're selling a
supplement, you're going to look at
what's the most unique ingredient or
what's the most unique combination of
two ingredients or all the ingredients.
What about the spokesperson, right? Um,
so spokesperson mechanism, delivery
mechanism, ingredients, packaging,
mental association, zeitgeist. So you're
looking at all of these things to figure
out what is unique about this solution.
So when I go through it, it's called
PDRN. That's really the hero product. So
I have to pretty much use that, right?
And it is kind of interesting. Is it the
most novel thing in the world? No. But
it is novel to a lot of people. A lot of
people haven't heard of it. And those
who have heard of it, we have some other
things that we could uh do to support
it, right? hyaluronic acid. A lot of
this stuff is kind of simple and doesn't
really make sense to me. Okay. Um maybe
the growth factor or the peptides, but
that stuff seems kind of like like
they're good ingredients and we can talk
about them, but they don't make this
thing unique. Uh the spokesperson,
there's really no spokesperson on this
page
um who has an interesting story, so I'm
not going to use that. Uh however the
delivery mechanism is interesting
because they use
uh 24 karat uh gold micro needles which
is unique. So this combination to me of
PDRN with this micro needling I know is
the combination that works. So what I
need to do is start reverse engineering
and coming back to the lab and saying
all right let me basically imagine or
think that uh let me come up with a
worldview for why salmon PDRN plus gold
micro needling is the absolute best
platonic ideal to a solution to
anti-aging.
Okay so we already found what's most
unique about this product and I'm going
way faster this usually takes time. Next
thing is how can we make those elements
preeeminent a category of one aka the
mostest bestest prettiest. So what is it
about PDRN that would make this the
absolute best uh possible skinincare
ingredient?
Okay. So like what would have to be true
about PDRN to make it whatever? So I
start going to the most common places.
Well, salmon. If it's derived from
salmon, then I will ask myself the
question, what is preeminent
about salmon? And I'm going to start
thinking about my associations, magical
thinking.
I'm gonna start thinking about what what
are my associations with salmon, right?
And so the things that I know like folk
wise is like the the one thing that pops
to my mind and again this is why it's
important to be curious and well read.
Um not that this is like some kind of
stroke of genius. I'm just saying you
want to have quick recollection of ideas
like this is I know salmon swim
upstream. I also know they get all like
bloody and bruised. So then I would go
and ask the question like um do salmon
regenerate their skin or scales, right?
I would ask myself that question. Um and
basically I'm going to go and I'm going
to look on clawed or whatever and I'm
going to ask myself questions around
like tell me about salmon swimming
upstream. Tell me about uh this kind of
stuff. Let me let me show you an
example. Okay, so I'll take you into
some of this a little bit. So tell me
about salmon swimming upstream and how
they get bruised and battered and have
to have their skin regenerate quickly.
So, salmon swimming upstream. They take
a real beating. Uh
again, I ignore the part that I don't
want to read. It doesn't matter to me.
Fish skin does regenerate faster than
mammal skin in general. I'm saying, how
do they compare to other animals? What's
possible to say about the preeminence in
the skin recovery or rejuvenation?
Right? So, I'm skipping all this [__]
Basically saying saying that uh they
endure physical punishment. Fish skin
heals faster and cleaner than mammal
skin. Salmon skin is rich in collagen.
They're preeminent uh at skin
regeneration. Well, it says it's not
really defensible, but basically this
stuff is used in wound care, things like
that. Then I'm asking about PDRN and the
primary mechanical mechanisms of action.
So, we have the option of receptor
activation or uh pathway fuel, right?
So, the big idea is either it's
triggering a signal or it's restoring
molecules. You can choose whichever one
you want. To me, the idea of injecting
something and it's actually feeding my
skin and rejuvenating it and providing
it something seems uh more important to
me.
So, here we go. Against the current
leaping waterfalls, whatever,
right? So there's some stuff in here and
I would play around with those ideas.
But you can see I'm starting to build a
story, right, about how salmon are
preeminent because they go on this crazy
journey that no other animal does. So
they have to regenerate their skin. So
if you take their DNA or you take
whatever, which is basically their
sperm. We're not going to say sperm
because that sounds [__] gross. So
we're taking their DNA and we're
injecting it and it's going to
rejuvenate your own skin. Okay? So we're
already starting to get there. Next
thing I would ask myself is this is an
example of magical thinking and
associations is I would just ask people
to and I did this on a call. I was like,
"Put these in order."
Like, "Rank them like one one to three."
And I wouldn't tell them how they're
ranking them, but most people would
start to rank things in this order. And
then I'm asking like why? And it's
basically because caviar is more
expensive and trout just seems uglier.
And it's really because the word is
ugly. I actually think trout may be more
expensive than salmon. Okay? Or like
tilapia
for instance, right? Like people will
kind of order these things like this.
So, what this shows and proves is that
people already have pre-built
associations. And salmon is nice. It's a
premiumish fish, but it's not as nice as
like caviar or some of these other ones.
Okay. So, I'm asking the question, how
can I make salmon seem more interesting?
So, then I ask myself a question like,
uh,
where are all the places that salmon
are from and different types of them?
Now again, a lot of this you do need to
balance it with the science and the
facts and things like that. Right? But
you I'm starting to think about what's
the best idea possible so then I can
work my way backwards to make things
that are true now. What I'm going to try
to figure out are what are what's a
salmon that sounds like really really
cool. So then I'm like, oh, I'm reading
through these and uh and then I see this
thing. Oh, cherry salmon, right? And
it's available in Japan, Korea, and
Russia. And then I'm like, oh, like
Korea has all these like skinincare
things. So Korean and it's cherry
salmon. Doesn't that sound like sexy?
Right. So PDRN
derived from uh Korean cherry salmon.
Like that sounds way sexier than um you
know salmon sperm coming from a sakkeye
a Russia you know a farm raised whatever
from chum. You know what I mean? That's
how you want to play around with those
magical thinking and associations.
All right. So you can see we're starting
to build up our case and then we're
going to say how can we make this
specific unique combination the perfect
combination at our current time and
place. Right? So we could tell this
story of um you know salmon
are unique.
They have the craziest journey.
Oh then the next thing I would say is
like the gold micro needling. So why
gold, right? What's the story of gold?
VA is valuable because it's blank blank
blank, right? And now and we need the
micro needles because if you ingest it,
it won't come in. So now we're starting
to play around and we're coming up with
this coherent shape for uh for what our
mechanism is going to be. Okay, so
that's one small example. I know we went
really fast for sake of time, but on the
next video I'll go a little bit deeper
and hopefully you can kind of sit with
this and and start to connect some dots
for yourself. So let me know down below
if this is valuable. Let me know other
video ideas or things that you want to
see.